breaking news meine damen und herren
denn die erste flut bilanz der
bundesregierung liegt vor wir haben das
papier gerade bekommen im juli wir
erinnern uns trifft die flut deutschland
zerstört häuser straßen bahntrassen in
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz
sachsen und bayern über 800 menschen
werden verletzt
183 sterben jetzt liegt dieses papier
von innen und finanzministerium vor dass
das ganze ausmaß deutlich macht der
zwischenbericht der flutkatastrophe
2021 und wir wollen jetzt mal auf die
wichtigsten aspekte darauf schauen
betrieb hier die schäden die werden
nämlich beziffert die schäden der
privathaushalte belaufen sich auf 14,3
milliarden euro bei der staatlichen
infrastruktur also brücken strassen
zugverbindungen zum beispiel liegt die
summe der schäden bei 17 milliarden euro
das system des bevölkerungsschutzes hat
sich laut des papiers als zitat
grundsätzlich trag- und leistungsfähig
erwiesen etwas was wir hier dieser
sendung gleich besprechen werden von
fehlern die gemacht wurden steht nämlich
nichts in dem zwischenbericht des in
neun finanzministeriums also
grundsätzlich tragen und leistungsfähig
so heißt es hier wörtlich trotzdem solle
das system des bevölkerungsschutzes aber
weiter evaluiert werden wie es heißt
also zu deutsch es muss noch mal geprüft
werden nix falsch gemacht
also wir kommen offensichtlich nicht aus
diesem
behördendeutsch gehörten deutschland
raus wenn das die tonalität dieses
gutachten sie verstehe das nicht
geschrieben ist wie ein spannendes villa
oder roman aber wenn dort in den fokus
gerückt wird wie viel milliarden schaden
entstanden ist ohne auch auf die frage
einzugehen oder bzw das wirft die frage
auf wer bezahlt denn dann eigentlich und
wenn es dann gipfelt in zwei sachen dass
wenn ich das richtig sehe von den toten
irgendwie kein wort da drin steht und
das auch nicht drin steht
das krasse fehler gab das aufgedeckt
dass die infrastruktur unseres landes er
nicht in der lage ist auf katastrophen
zu reagieren das ist sozusagen ein
symbol ist es uns aufwecken muss unsere
infrastrukturen komplett zu überdenken
wenn das alles in dem wort wir müssen
das jetzt halt ein bisschen evaluieren
gipfelt dann ist schon der einstieg in
die aufarbeitung wieder schief gegangen
evaluieren heißt es immer wieder werden
damals über die flut berichtet klaus
haben diese bilder gesehen die
verzweiflung der menschen die zerstörung
und auch noch heute stehen so viele
menschen vor den trümmern ihrer existenz
sie schauen jetzt einen winzer haben zum
teil keinen strom haben kein warmes
wasser und haben zum teil auch immer
noch kein zuhause und auch keine hilfe
und jetzt bekommt man das schwarz auf
weiß alles steht drin ja wir müssen noch
einmal evaluieren also ich finde es ist
ein schlag ins gesicht der direkt
betroffenen und es ist auch ein schlag
ins gesicht aller bürger die sich darauf
verlassen wollen dass dieser staat in
krisensituationen in notsituationen für
uns da ist nicht gerade dafür bezahlen
wir ihn dafür bezahlen wir unsere
steuern und dafür wählen wer seine
vertreter und dann müssen glaube ich
diese menschen auch in der aufarbeitung
erstens ein bisschen emotionalität
zeigen ehrliche nicht geheuchelt und
zweitens müssen sie ihre eigenen
fehlleistungen für die sie
verantwortlich sind auch benennen sonst
kann man sie nämlich nicht lösen ich
habe gerade mal ein bisschen geblättert
während ihr gesprochen habt und in der
tat immerhin muss man sagen steht hier
und das ist andererseits ein brutales
eingeständnis dass deutsche
hilfeleistungssystem verdankt seine
leistungsstärke in erster linie den
zahlreichen ehrenamtlichen helferinnen
und helfern die
haben ja einen tollen job gemacht aber
es wird auch wenn ich dass wir jetzt
ganz brandneu wie durch uns kommt diese
nachricht dass sozusagen erst unter die
leute werden das gleich im nachgang mal
studieren aber es muss doch irgendwo
klar werden das krasse fehler passiert
sind das ist große defizite gab das
alles was wir jetzt raus lesen und hören
klingt so als wäre eigentlich alles im
großen und ganzen ganz gut gelaufen aber
es gibt ein paar hundert tote und haufen
milliarden start dennoch ein
interessanter punkt welcher die
zuständigkeit der länder also der
föderalismus für den kattas strophen
schutz hat sich auch bei der bewältigung
des hochwassers in diesem jahr bewährt
also wenn wir jetzt noch vier absätze
vorlesen wo sich irgendwas bewährt hat
gleich verrückt also es wird am ende
wenn man das durchgelesen hat ist man
zitiert und denkt es mag am liebsten
feigl auf es war wirklich sensationell
gut wie wir das alles gemacht habe diese
idioten von journalisten die sich
darüber aufregen diese weicheier und
mengen von menschen deren häuser
abgesoffen sind und toten betrauert
haben ist dem polizeiapparat doch gar
nix wir haben uns bewährt es hat sich
bewahrheitet das ist richtig ist wir
müssen ein bisschen rum evaluieren aber
im großen und ganzen hat doch alles
geklappt und wisst ihr was jetzt in
meinem kopf ist gab es nicht sogar den
satz von frau merkel im großen und
ganzen hat alles geklappt zur pandemie
das war einer ihrer sätze zur pandemie
und der ist im grunde auch wieder rein
gerutscht in die aufarbeitung der flut
was ist denn mit uns los
[Musik]